et au total plus de 3 millions de
personnes ont déjà fui le cren depuis le
début de l'offensive russe il y a trois
semaines et ils sont chaque jour plus
nombreux plus de cent mille personnes
ont quitté le pays ces dernières 24
heures selon l'onu le conseil de
l'europe vous le disent dans les titres
alerte d'ailleurs contre les risques
pour ces réfugiés de tomber dans des
réseaux de trafic d'êtres humains pour
en parler nous sommes avec geneviève
colas coordinatrice du collectif
ensemble contre la traite des êtres
humains pour le secours catholique
caritas france geneviève colas bonsoir
merci à vous d'être avec nous sur france
parmi ces exilés c'est plus de 3
millions de personnes qui ont fui le
pays depuis le début de cette guerre il
ya surtout des femmes et des enfants
puisque les hommes sont restés pour
combattre des populations
particulièrement vulnérables
psychologiquement meurtri bon
l'imaginent quels sont les risques
auxquels ils doivent faire face
aujourd'hui lorsqu'ils traversent ses
frontières alors un risque très
important c'est le risque d'exploitation
les risques de traite des êtres humains
l'exploitation sous toutes ses formes
c'est à dire l'exploitation sexuelle
contrainte à commettre des délits
travail forcé
obligations à mendier ce sont vraiment
des risques d'exploitation sous toutes
leurs formes
c'est aussi le risque pour les enfants
de disparaître parce que dont se sait
par expérience d'autres conflits dans
ses mouvements de population il ya des
enfants parfois qui disparaissent et qui
peuvent se retrouver exploité dans
différents pays finalement en fait à la
fois dans le pays d'accueil mais souvent
aussi dans d'autres pays autour
exploiter pour faire quoi par exemple
exploiter pour par exemple être
contraint à voler
dans le métro dans les gares voilà être
contraint à faire d'eux les être esclave
moderne c'est-à-dire au début on demande
d'aidé un peu une famille à garder les
enfants à s'occuper des repas et puis
après quelques fois ça tourne grand en
travail pour aider pour un hôte un hôtel
ou pour 1 1
un restaurant faire des repas préparé
des choses pour quelque chose d'
économique ou alors encore exploitation
sexuelle est
en fait souvent malgré tout il ya des
cumuls de tout cela en fait est-ce que
vous avez déjà reçu depuis trois
semaines des témoignages de travailleurs
humanitaires qui sont à cette frontière
en moldavie ou encore en pologne est-ce
que les trafiquants sont plus en plus
visible alors de plus en plus visible je
ne sais pas mais sont de plus en plus
suivi c'est à dire que il ya de plus en
plus d'éléments qui sont mis en oeuvre à
la fois par la société civile par la
police
et la justice pour pouvoir repérer ces
personnes là et donc du coup on en
repère plus maintenant imagine que c'est
très difficile de les repérer oui c'est
difficile en fait c'est difficile et
puis il faut se méfier c'est à dire que
on a un certain nombre de critères parce
qu'on sait ce qui s'est passé dans
d'autres conflits est ce que ça peu ce
qui se passe quand les gens traversent
la frontière très vite
avec des mineurs qui le traverse tout
seul et qui finacement suivent parfois
des adultes et ces adultes sont pas
toujours des adultes bon bienveillant
donc il faut en fait que tout le monde à
la fois dans la police dans la justice
dans l'est dans le travail social dans
la santé dans l'éducation que tout le
monde soit bien sensibilisés à cette
question là pour pouvoir avoir l'oeil
aiguisé et au moins se dire qu'il ya
peut-être un risque et pouvoir en fait
faire en sorte de pouvoir faire des
vérifications en même temps plus de 3
millions de personnes en seulement trois
semaines c'est considérable
ça paraît compliqué dans ce contexte de
contrôler comme vous le dites oui alors
après les organisations humanitaires ont
l'habitude de travailler avec des nombre
important de personnes d'accuellir
dénombra par 102 personnes de les
enregistrer c'est des choses très
importantes en fait donc il ya quand
même beaucoup
d'organisations humanitaires ou encore
aussi de travail qui est fait aux
frontières pour permettre
l'enregistrement des personnes qui va
permettre d'éviter qu'ils soient qu'ils
partent avec le premier venu et qui
puissent leur arriver quelque chose que
comment s'occuper vous l'avez évoqué ces
mineurs qui se retrouva à la frontière
ils sont très nombreux il ya aussi des
orphelins qui ont quitté les orphelinats
d'ukraine et qui se retrouve seul
aujourd'hui dans des pays européens
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour les
accompagner ces jeunes la première chose
faut les prendre en charge tout de suite
dès que ont dès qu'on sait qu'ils sont
là dès qu'on a pu les croiser que ce
soit la gare que ce soit en fait en
général ils sont pas tout seuls ils sont
avec d'autres ils sont avec des familles
avec qui sont venus mais ils vont vite
être un poids pour ces familles en
question donc il faut très vite pouvoir
les enregistrer et puis ensuite leur
permettent d'être dans un parcours que
l'on peut proposer à tout enfant
normalement en france qui arrive et qui
est mineure
normalement donc il a droit d'être pris
en charge par les services sociaux dans
le sachet cas en france où c'est le cas
aussi dans les autres pays c'est partout
c'est partout que il faut qu'il soit
pris en compte en france normalement ces
mineurs sont pris en compte la
difficulté qu'on rencontre souvent avec
les mineurs non accompagnés
c'est ainsi qu'on les appelle c'est que
en fait parfois on dit ah ben non ils
nous disent qu ils ont l âge mais en
fait ils sont plus grands et on les
prend pas en charge et c'est une grosse
erreur parce que dans tous les cas les
laisser à la rue c'est le et risquer de
les mettre à face à une situation des
coûts d'exploitation ou
que il fasse n'importe quoi parce que
parce que pour survivre il va bien
falloir qu'ils aient accès à l'aller
c'est un phénomène d'ailleurs qui existe
déjà dans les rues de certaines grandes
villes européennes tout à fait et c'est
ce même en france ça existe avec
d'autres nationalités est ce qu'on dit
c'est certainement que cette crise en
ukraine ça doit être l'occasion
absolument de prendre mieux en compte
cette question des mineurs
non-accompagnés quelle que soit leur
nationalité
parce que là on est en train de parler
de faire des choses spécifiques pour les
ukrainiens c'est bien mais il ya
d'autres pays en guerre il ya d'autres
personnes qui arrivent de pays en guerre
un enfant c'est un enfant il faut aider
tous les enfants et les femmes aussi les
femmes sont très vulnérables aussi bien
sûr parce que les femmes en plus parfois
elles ont des enfants et donc la charge
des familles donc c'est quand même un
poids aussi pour elle
et parfois les accepterai beaucoup de
choses pour le bien-être de leurs
enfants et c'est là qu'elle risque
d'être exploités soit par le travail par
de l'aide à domicile mais qui prend des
tournures où on leur laisse plus le
temps de respirer soit par des de
l'exploitation sexuelle malheureusement
c'est ce serait très souvent le cas
quels conseils vous pouvez leur donner à
ces femmes pour éviter justement de
tomber dans ses réseaux alors la
première chose c'est
de ne pas accepter n'importe quel
travail donc il faut qu'on sensibilise
ces personnes qui arrivent aux quelque
part au droit du travail en france est
en fait en tout cas à comment
s'organiser pour pas tomber dans
n'importe quel petit boulot qui risque
de les mettre dans une situation
finalement d'emprise emprise d'une
personne sur elle qui va pouvoir soit
seul soit en réseau l'exploiter parce
que les deux cas sont existe en fait on
parle souvent des réseaux criminels mais
parfois ce sont des individus aussi et
voilà il faut pas accepter ni de la part
d'individus ni une ni deux la part de
réseaux criminels la moindre
exploitation ce qui est difficile c'est
que souvent en fait on attend un peu
trop et et l'exploitation l empire elle
s'installe au début on essaie de les
trafiquants essaye de prendre une
certaine confiance de la personne et
c'est pas au début qu'on va tout de
suite il m'a immédiatement se rendent
compte que la personne va abuser et donc
c'est quelque chose en effet qui demande
bas de la sensibilisation de la par
rapport aux personnes directement
concernées mais aussi de la formation de
toutes les personnes qui sont autour les
la justice la police l'éducation
nationale etc il faut très vite
scolariser les enfants mais les enfants
il faut les scolariser avec une qu'ils
aient une chance de réussir c'est à dire
dans des classes où ils vont pouvoir
avoir la possibilité d'apprendre la
langue française de pouvoir rentrer
correctement
dando il faut en effet prendre en compte
très particulièrement ces personnes pour
faire de la prévention merci beaucoup
geneviève que la star était notre invité
ce soir sur france 24